multiple sclerosis literally means  multiple scars throughout the spinal  cord and the nervous system  the major reason behind this is  the demyelination of the neurons  and this demyelination is due to immune  attack on the myelin sheaths  if we see the brain of a multiple  sclerosis patient there would be scars  throughout the brain and in the spinal  cord  multiple sclerosis could be occurring  due to genetic or environmental factors  and the overall pathology is  defined by three terms which is known as  charcot's neurologic triad  dysarthria  nystagmus and intention trimmers  diagnosis of multiple sclerosis can be  done using mri there is currently no  treatment for multiple sclerosis but  there are particular treatment which can  take care of the symptoms  subscribe